hey 42 here when it's been a long year
and you're in desperate need of some
rest and relaxation nothing compares
with an island holiday the ocean breeze
the soothing sound of waves lapping on
the shore the tinkling of ice in your
glass
the incinerating heat of a nuclear blast
okay a nuclear blast is probably not
something you need to concern yourself
with next time you're heading for hawaii
or the maldives
but perhaps double check with your
travel agent
because it turns out that islands rank
really high on the list of stuff humans
like to blow up at least it seems that
small spits of land in the ocean really
piss off the united states
because in july 1946 they performed the
first public test of a nuclear weapon by
dropping an atomic bomb on bikini atop
a collection of small islands within the
larger marshall islands group in the
pacific ocean as an aside it was around
this time that frenchman louie reard
invented what we know today as the
bikini even though by today's standards
it looked a bit something like what your
gram would wear because she probably did
however it was much skimpier than any
bathing costume that had come before
so when the us dropped the bomb
literally on the bikini atoll just four
days before reard was to debut his new
two-piece swimsuit
the opportunistic inventor capitalized
on all the news headlines and publicity
by naming his new product the bikini
knowing that it was likely to be an
explosive launch
he later patented the name and the rest
is history there is a related anecdote
about the mankini at all but
really that's a story everyone would
rather forget anyway back to the weapons
of mass destruction between 1948 and
1956 the united states dropped 67
nuclear bombs on or above the marshall
islands
creating massive craters and making
entire islands disappear
in 1952 the first hydrogen bomb was
tested on their enewy tuckatol also part
of the marshall islands
and then in november 1971 the united
states conducted its most powerful
underground nuclear test to date
by detonating a nuclear warhead one mile
below ground on the remote amchiteka
island in alaska however none of these
hold a radioactive candle to the utter
contempt russia clearly holds for
islands particularly the archipelago of
novaya zemla located in far north russia
in the arctic ocean it was designated as
a nuclear testing site in 1954.
since then it has seen
224 nuclear detonations with explosive
energy totaling 265
megatons of tnt
all the explosions used in the second
world war including the two atomic bombs
dropped on japan
only came to two megatons of tnt
nevia zemla's greatest moment if you can
call it that came in october 1961 when
the soviet union used it as the test
site
for the most powerful bomb in history
the sarbomba
russian for king of bombs it was almost
eight meters long two meters in diameter
and weighed 27 tons there was no plane
big enough to carry it so one had to be
modified especially for the job the
construction of sarbomba may seem a
little random
like they just woke up one more ingam
thought mother russia must build biggest
bomb ever it is destiny but it was
actually a very typical move for russia
and just another object in a series of
really big russian [ __ ] built in 1586
sarkanon is the largest cannon by
caliber in the world it's made of solid
bronze measures more than 5 meters in
length and weighs in at 40 tons
sar bell is
you guessed it the largest bell in the
world even though it's never been wrung
or even hung up which isn't surprising
considering it weighs more than 200 tons
and is two stories high so there were
certainly a few eye rolls and thoughts
of
here we go again when soviet premier
nikita khrushchev commissions the
construction of sarbomba in july
he even called the bomb kusko's mother a
reference to an old russian proverb
meaning you're about to teach someone a
harsh unforgettable lesson but this time
the bigger is better philosophy
delivered some pretty tangible results
the impact of sarbomba
was devastating
even though it detonated four kilometers
above the earth it wiped the land below
it clean
ground zero was reported to appear
leveled swept and licked so that it
looked like a skating rink observers
felt the heat from the blast 170 miles
away whilst anyone within 70 miles
experienced third degree burns
that's about the distance from new york
to philadelphia by the way
the flash from the explosion was seen
620 miles away
through bad weather and windows as far
away as norway and finland were
shattered by the force
the bomb's mushroom cloud reached 40
miles into the sky just below the edge
of space shock waves from the blast
travelled around the earth three times
you may be asking yourself what's the
point
why on earth would anyone want to invent
something that could vaporize entire
cities well i think you probably already
know the answer to that it's the same as
the answer to
why do countries have military parades
why do people drive hummers or why do
bodybuilders wear tight shirts
as a display of power
sar bomber was constructed in the early
60s just as the cold war started to heat
up
or cool down
whatever the united states and the
soviet union were taking turns flexing
their muscles and proving just how
powerful they were by blowing stuff up
until that point the most enormous
detonation ever recorded was the 15
megaton castle bravo hydrogen bomb
dropped by the us on yes bikini at all 1
000 times more potent than the hiroshima
bomb it decimated everything on free
islands
raised water temperatures to 55 000
degrees and left a crater that was more
than a mile wide and 70 meters deep so
when khrushchev ordered sarbamba to be
built he had but one purpose in mind
to put an end to the ongoing to and fro
between the world's superpowers and
prove once and for all that the soviet
union was the big daddy
he originally wanted the king of bombs
to be a 100 megaton monster
but due to various constraints
nuclear physicists eventually settled on
a 50 megaton device
don't you just hate it when you're
designing a bomb and your nuclear yield
gets cut in half
even with a measly 50 megatons in their
cargo holes the pilots who drops to the
bomb were told they only had a 50 50
chance of survival
and that proved to be pretty accurate
they only barely survived after the
plane was knocked out of the sky by the
blast and plummeted three thousand feet
before writing itself if you're sitting
there thinking blimey that sure sounds
impressive
but what does 50 megatons even mean
allow me to explain explosions of all
kinds are measured in a tnt equivalent
one gram of the explosive chemical
compound trinita toluene also known as
tnt for obvious reasons releases 4 000
joules of energy
so
a one kiloton bomb releases the same
amount of energy as one thousand tons of
tnt which is a lot of joules
a 50 megaton bomb releases roughly the
same energy as 50 million tons of tnt
and so on for context the energy
contained in one megaton of tnt is
enough to power the average american
household for 1000 years the energy in a
30 megaton blast could power the same
home for more than three million years
or the entire united states for three
days
in the end it appears khrushchev's plan
worked
the sar bomba was a cold war mic drop
and two years later the united states
soviet union and great britain
established the partial nuclear test ban
treaty
limiting all test detonations of nuclear
weapons to underground but this treaty
didn't equate to the world bowing to
russia's military might instead it was a
long overdue wake-up call humanity had
had more than a taste of how devastating
a thermonuclear blast can be
and it seems to have scared everyone
back into line
at least for a while of course for most
of us regular folk who are more
concerned with choosing a tasty yet
conveniently high-fiber breakfast cereal
rather than blowing up the planet this
is good news
fortunately sarbomba was too big to be
used in actual battle but what if we
developed the technology to deliver that
same destructive force in a more
convenient package
the resulting damage to human life from
a 100 megaton bomb being dropped over a
major metropolitan area doesn't bear
thinking about in london that would
translate to roughly 6 million
fatalities
in new york 8 million
tokyo 14 million
the fort is sickening even those
involved in nuclear arms development
have come to regret it the nuclear
physicist who led the creation of the
world's biggest bomb andrei sakharov
became a strong supporter of imposing
limitations on these tests he was
horrified by what he'd built as well as
the cumulative effects of nuclear
weapons testing regions like navoya
zemla and the marshall islands have
suffered significant ecological damage
and show increased levels of radioactive
elements at some spots in enewetoc where
the first hydrogen bomb was tested and
other parts of the marshall islands show
radiation levels similar to those found
near chernobyl and fukushima sakarov
became an outspoken critic of soviet
weapons plans and a civil rights
activist in the soviet union eventually
receiving the nobel peace prize in 1975
this is especially ironic since the
founder of the nobel prize swedish
chemist inventor and engineer alfred
nobel was perhaps most famous for his
invention of one of the most enduring
explosive materials of all time
dynamite
another key figure who turned his back
on nuclear weaponry was j robert
oppenheimer
as the leader of the manhattan project
oppenheimer is credited with creating
humankind's first atomic bomb
but after the weapon was used against
japan in world war ii oppenheimer began
to regret what he'd helped create
he felt responsible for the nuclear arms
race that followed and deeply opposed
the development of the h-bomb or
hydrogen bomb
saying that it was too powerful for
humans to control
after sarbomba which was an h-bomb
it seems that he may be right even
though the development and testing of
thermonuclear devices has slowed in
recent decades
we shouldn't naively assume this spells
the end of humanity's appetite for
really powerful blowy-up type things
sadly nuclear may only be the beginning
one theoretical possibility is an
anti-matter bomb
its destructive potential is beyond
anything we've ever imagined never mind
created
just half a gram of antimatter would be
enough to build a bomb that releases 40
percent more energy than that dropped on
hiroshima that means that just one and a
half kilograms of antimatter would be
needed to deliver the same explosive
force as the 27 ton sar bomber but every
apocalyptic cloud has a not so shitty
lining and an anti-mata bomb wouldn't
lead to much nuclear fallout that's all
the radiation left behind after an
atomic or hydrogen bomb so it would be
in a really weird way a clean explosion
but i doubt that would be much
consolation to the people it lands on
it's like saying i only drink organic
cyanide fortunately there are a few
hurdles that are likely to ensure we're
still some time away from seeing an
anti-matter weapon in action the
explosive power of antimatter comes from
the fact that as soon as it comes into
contact with ordinary matter the two
annihilate each other
releasing extraordinary amounts of
energy
obviously this makes containing it and
moving it around
more than a little bit tricky
as soon as antimatter comes into contact
with the size of the tupperware
container you've put it in
boom no more tupperware and no more you
the second problem is supply the
universe is made up of considerably more
matter than antimatter
if it were 50 50 one would cancel out
the other and there'd be no universe
left it would be like a really really
empty disco party and i say disco
because disco can't die partly due to
this bias towards mata antimatter has
proved extremely difficult to find at
cern the largest particle physics
laboratory in the world
scientists have amongst lots of other
geeky things spent the last 30 years
trying to harvest antimatter so far
they've got their hands on 10 billionths
of a gram possibly enough to light a
match it's not a cheap exercise either
the current costs of production of
antimatter are about 62 million dollars
per gram
so it seems that we're safe from the
bomb that will blow up the world for the
time being that's not to say total
planetary destruction is not on the
cards though
nature itself is considerably more
powerful than anything humans have come
close to creating the 1883 eruption of
krakatoa a volcano near indonesia
was four times more powerful than
sarbomba
the total energy released by the 1815
eruption of mount tambora on the island
of sambawa was estimated to be more than
600 times bigger than sarbomba
the most energetic event in earth's
history was the chick-zulub meteor
impact that caused mass extinction and
ended the reign of the dinosaurs that
was 2
million times more powerful than
sarbomba
a bit embarrassing really
i'm not saying that you shouldn't keep
an eye on psychopathic totalitarian
dictators with an itch for nuclear
warfare
i'm just saying there's a lot of stuff
out there that's a lot scarier of course
there's nothing you can do about it
though so keep calm and carry on
thanks for watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts available on youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts link in the
description below thanks